[MUSIC PLAYING]
WEI LIN: I'm a senior
director of PAI,
the platform of artificial
intelligence in Alibaba.
Today I will give you a brief
introduction about our work.
This is an overview of
our computation platform.
We have a global
storage system with
the heterogeneous resource.
On top that we have
uniform resource management
to support all different types
of computation framework,
including PAI.
Here's a snapshot of
the PAI user interface.
People can pull and try
components, and build
a workflow very easily.
The system runs on top
of millions of CPU cores,
and thousands of GPU cores.
Our single training job can
scale up to a thousand workers,
with billions of
features and parameters.
And we also have a public
server in our cloud
for the external user as well.
Here is our key in
our system design.
We want to have some
easy-going building blocks
for AI application creators.
We also provide-- cover the full
web cycle for those developers,
to give them a one-stop
programming experience.
Our core is our engine
which can provide
high performance, low cost, good
flexibility, and extensibility.
Since this is a
TensorFlow dev summit,
I will talk more about our work
in the deep learning engine.
Our ultimate goal is to let the
developer focus on modelling
their neural network.
Net assistant, PAI, helps
them run their model easily,
efficiently, and to scale.
How do we achieve that?
We deeply leverage
TensorFlow, because TensorFlow
has a very good flexible and
extensible system design.
And we did a lot of
in-depth optimization,
which is listed on the right.
Inside Alibaba, the
recommendation system
has billions of
features that requires
a thousand workers in training.
We have to enhance TensorFlow,
especially on the runtime
and distributed
training mechanism,
to leverage the sparsity
of the data better.
We also improved the
communication protocol
to introduce this
multi-layer, or reduced ring,
to build on top of the
network hierarchy topology.
We also support different
communication protocols,
like RDMA and NCCL.
In order to fully utilize
new GPU architecture
like [INAUDIBLE].
We enhanced a TensorFlow
that can automatically run
the model with mixed precision.
From the initial
results, we actually
improved this three times
in our real scenarios.
We asked for easy programming.
We worked with the
community together,
to improve the auto-parallelism.
We introduced TAO, which is
based on the XLA framework,
and that did a lot
of the optimization.
Including the cost-based graph
split, graph optimization,
kernel fusion, and
full-stage code-gen.
On the inference side, we
introduced the PAI-Blade tools,
which has three levels
of optimization.
Here are some results.
We can see that on
those public models,
we are on par with TensorRT.
Slightly better.
Recently, graph neural networks
gained a lot of attention
inside Alibaba.
In our real scenario, we faced
a more challenging [INAUDIBLE] ,
group, having four properties.
They are large-scale
heterogeneous, attributed,
and dynamic.
We had to enhance TensorFlow
to solve those challenges.
We also developed a general
CN inference engine,
with-- on FPGA, and integrated
this engine with TensorFlow.
We have deployed this solution
to our CityBrain project
in China.
PAI also provide
a lot of the SDK
for the developer to
accelerate their research,
including Reinforcement
Learning, Transfer Learning
package, and the Computation
Vision natural language
processing.
They are all built up
on top of TensorFlow.
Currently we already
contributed a lot--
50-- probably more
than 50 PRs back.
I came here to want to
have more connection,
and to try to share more of
our work with the community.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]